Shanah Tovah the theory of impeachment
keeps changing Democrats keep pushing
full steam ahead and President Trump
continues to lash out in all directions
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show so when last we left our
impeachment story last friday as
preparing for Rosh Hashanah I figured
not much would happen over the weekend
and turns out not much did happen over
the weekend except that the theory of
impeachment keeps changing so back on
Thursday and Friday the theory of
impeachment seemed to still be sort of
that President Trump had engaged in a
quid pro quo with the Ukrainian
government in which he basically
threatened to withhold aid American aid
military aid to Ukraine in exchange for
the Ukrainian government checking out
his chief domestic political opponent
Joe Biden well as it turns out over the
past couple of days it appears and I'm
just catching up on the news it appears
that the theory of impeachment is now
changing it is malleable that Democrats
weren't able to come up with the quid
pro quo they were seeking on the
specific transcript of this phone call
that Trump had with Ukraine and so now
they are attempting to construct another
impeachment based crime and that would
be obstruction of justice they are
trying to come up with some rationale
why they can blame the Trump
administration for blocking the
investigation now doesn't matter that
the Trump administration turned over the
transcript doesn't matter they turned
over the whistle blower report doesn't
matter that the witnesses who have been
requested by the house thus far have
basically been scheduled so far as I can
tell including the former ambassador to
Ukraine as well as other officials
American officials from the State
Department who are active in Ukraine
still the Democrats are pushing forward
with the idea that if we can't get them
for the underlying crime will get
president from for obstruction that
seems to be one angle and then there's
the generalized Democratic angle and you
can see this happening in the press
which is that impeachment isn't truly
about what Trump did here impeachment
isn't truly about any specific criminal
allegation impeachment is about trumping
a poopoo head that really seems to
really that's the case and as we will
see today the Democrats keep broadening
out the case so we are now seeing them
begin to speak with more and more wild
language about what a bad guy Trump is
well Trump may be a bad guy according to
Democrats that is not an impeachable
offense being somebody that people don't
like being somebody who acts in ways you
don't like that's not
teachable I didn't like Barack Obama
attitude was not impeached hey Bill
Clinton was impeached but that was for a
specific crime that was not because
people didn't like his tax policy in
1994 we had an election to fix his tax
policy in 1994
so as we will see as the impeachment
proceeding moves forward it seems less
like Democrats are honing in on any one
theory of impeachment and then getting
to the heart of it it seems instead that
like an octopus the tentacles are just
reaching out in every direction and
hopefully they can snag something that
will be sufficient to move the public so
that the public isn't anti impeachment
and it doesn't blow back on Democrats
okay so along those lines today the
media are making a very big deal out of
the fact that Mike Pompeo the Secretary
of State has now confirmed that he
listened to President Trump's call with
the Ukrainian president which isn't a
big surprise there are a lot of people
who are listening to that phone call the
Secretary of State very often frequently
listens to phone calls that the
president has with foreign leaders but
this was the first time the Pompeo had
openly acknowledged that that is
something that happened before he had
been asked about the whistleblower
complaint he said I never saw the
whistleblower complaint so I have no
specific answers about the whistleblower
complaint but he never said that he was
on the call itself so Democrats of
course are jumping to well this means
that it was a cover-up this means that
it was a cover-up except that it's not a
cover-up since he just said it he just
like the Democrats keep doing this they
did with Muller they did it with the
they did it with the whistleblower they
did it with the transcript of the phone
call and now they're doing it with
Pompeo they keep claiming that there is
a cover-up right about the point when
the Trump administration blows the whole
thing into public view right so here's
Pompeo explaining yes I was on the phone
call with Ukraine I was on the phone
call the phone call was in the context
of now I guess I've been the Secretary
of State for coming on a year-and-a-half
I know precisely what the American
policy is with respect to Ukraine it's
been remarkably consistent and we will
continue to try to drive those a set of
outcomes it's what our team included
including ambassador Volcker were
focused on was taking down the threat
that Russia poses there in Ukraine okay
so he was immediately asked of course
whether Trump did anything inappropriate
on the call
and he damn Ewart answer that question
he used to client answer the question
why well because the fact is that
President could have done things that
are inappropriate but not impeachable
but the fact is the Pompey also works
for Trump Trump is particularly
thin-skinned when it comes to this sort
of stuff he doesn't like when his own
officials are out there saying that he
does stuff that they don't approve of
this is what happened to John Bolton and
Mike Pompeo isn't about to fall into
that trap okay so this follows hard on
the Democrats claiming over the past 48
hours that Pompeo is somehow holding up
their access to State Department
officials so the New York Times reported
yesterday the Trump administration
clashed on Tuesday with leaders of the
house and Pietschmann inquiry over their
demands to questions State Department
officials who might have witnessed
president Trump's efforts to pressure
Ukraine for political advantage now
notice again that the the language here
used by the New York Times and it's been
used consistently by the media now is
that Trump was pressuring Ukraine as
opposed to requesting Ukraine which is a
more accurate description of that phone
call pressure on Ukraine would presume
oh I mean that assumes the the question
that is in doubt the question in doubt
is whether there was a quid pro quo
right not whether Trump asked for
something but whether there was a quid
pro quo and you use the word pressured
the assumption is that there is
something credible on the other end of
that pressure namely a threat so you
notice the word pressure whenever the
media used the word pressure and not the
word requested or asked you know that
then that is the media infusing their
own bias into a story in any case the
New York Times says in the first
skirmish and what promises to be an epic
impeachment struggle between the
executive and legislative branches
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo lashed
out at three congressional committees
that are seeking to deposed diplomats
involved in American policy toward
Ukraine mr. Pompeo called their demands
for confidential interviews an act of
intimidation now the reason that he says
that is because he is saying you're not
giving them time to get lawyers and deal
with State Department lawyers which by
the way if that sounds like somebody
covering up or somebody covering their
butt
let me assure you I know people who are
in who are questioned by the Muller
report their exam a lot of folks inside
the administration I know people who are
questioned by the Mullen report it cost
them at tens of thousands of dollars
with lawyers in order to be questioned
because anybody who goes in his question
by a government committee under oath
without a lawyer present at their side
to advise them on what they should and
should not say is a fool you would be a
fool
- and that has nothing to do with
truth-telling or not sure - telling it's
like going to deal with the IRS without
any lawyer on the line like doing that
is a fool's errand
they're literally putting you there so
that they can then charge you with some
form of perjury or misleading statement
and then they can use that to pressure
you to say things you don't want to say
Pompeyo is saying okay we need time to
get all these people the lawyers that
they want and the Democrats naturally
because they are attempting to gin up
some sort of belief that there is a
cover-up going on they are saying that
Pompeo is engaged in the cover-up when
again the two biggest officials who are
being questioned so far have already set
dates on which they're to be questioned
the house postponed the first of the
depositions which had been scheduled for
Wednesday with the former US ambassador
to Ukraine but not before the
impeachment inquiry leaders upbraided
Pompeo for questioning their work and
for asserting that their bid to swiftly
schedule depositions did not allow
enough time for a proper response the
latest standoff unfolded as lawmakers
were unexpectedly put on notice Tuesday
afternoon that it could soon be provided
with new evidence related to the State
Department and Ukraine a twist that
could add crucial information to their
investigation and potentially complicate
mr. Trump's efforts to block it we'll
get to what exactly that crucial piece
of information is and why Democrats in
the House are extraordinarily excited
about a visit from a member of the State
Department get to that in just one
second first let's talk about going to
the post office the fact is post office
pretty great place but you really want
to schlep all your packages in the back
of your car and then go down to the post
office and wait in line they offer a lot
of great services but you'd prefer to
save time and money no well this is why
you should be using stamps calm
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US postal office
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices or an
online seller shipping out products even
a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps comm can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just hand it to your mail
carrier or drop it in the mailbox it is
indeed that simple stamps.com it's a no
brainer saves you time saves you money
it's no wonder over 700,000 small
businesses
already use stamps com last time I went
to the post office I got a parking
ticket cuz there's only one thing that
the authorities in Los Angeles are good
at and no it is not cleaning up the
streets it is giving parking tickets so
I've vowed from then on I will only use
stamps calm so far I have
to my found it has saved me time and
money right now my listeners get a
special offer it includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and the digital
scale no long term commitment just go to
stamms com click on the microphone at
the top of the home page type in Shapiro
that is Sam's comm enter Shapiro okay so
why are the House Democrats is so
excited because the State Department's
independent watchdog wrote to several
House and Senate committees to request a
last-minute meeting on Wednesday to
discuss and provide staff with copies of
documents according to an invitation
reviewed by the New York Times so
they're very excited what are the
documents going to people we don't know
yet maybe when we know then we can
determine whether in fact there was
either a quid pro quo or a cover-up but
at this point we do not have evidence of
either and said the documents had been
given to the inspector general Stephen
linic by the State Department's acting
legal adviser but did not provide
additional information or indicate
whether mr. Pompeo was aware of the
action mr. Lennox office has not
responded to calls her email seeking
comment for two days the bitter
back-and-forth according to the New York
Times only one week after the house
started its impeachment inquiry
foreshadowed what could be a
consequential fight between the
administration and House Democrats they
are determined to quickly nail down
facts at the heart of the whistleblower
complaint well maybe the whole purpose
of the speed is because they know that
the executive branch is not going to
want to comply that quickly because it's
actually kind of complicated to comply
with subpoenas from the executive branch
you have to determine for example what
is classified and what is not classified
what the president is going to declare
executive privilege over and what he is
not you have to make sure that everybody
gets lawyers so by artificially boosting
the timeline
perhaps the goal here is for Democrats
to actually create exactly the sort of
conflict they are pretending they wish
to avoid the White House is just as
determined to thwart or at least slow
the investigation I do love the New York
Times language there they're just as
determined to thwart or at least slow
the investigation well which is it wart
or slow why don't you just say that they
are determined to slow that's obvious
but thwart is a different thing falling
back on the approach it has used to
stonewall efforts by Congress to delve
into episodes detail by robert muller
the special counsel who investigated
Russia's interference in the 2016
election okay so we have a few pieces of
competing news you have the the Pompeo
acknowledgment that he was in fact on
the phone call which doesn't actually
mean anything unless there were
something wrong with the phone call
itself you have the House
rats who are going to try and subpoena
members of Pompeo State Department and
Pompeyo saying hold up a second guys
you're moving too fast here and the
Democrats then claiming cover-up
and you have the State Department's
inspector general requesting an urgent
briefing with senior congressional staff
members after pump Hale pushed back on
House Democratic demands to turn over
documents so we are still wondering
exactly what exactly the only real piece
of news that the only real piece of news
is not the hubbub between Pompeo and
House Democrats and it's not really that
Pompeo was on the call because the call
would be just as criminal or non
criminal depending on whether Pompey was
there like Pompey was presence doesn't
change the tenor of the phone call
unless the case is somehow that Pompeo
was the hatchet man for the quid pro quo
but that even that doesn't answer the
question as to whether there was in fact
a quid pro quo the real piece of news
here is that there may be new
information that emerges thanks to the
State Department Inspector General's
request one congressional aide described
the state's Inspector General's request
as highly unusual and cryptically worded
the inspector general again said the
reason for the briefing was that they
had obtained documents from an acting
legal adviser in the State Department
but as I say you know all this talk
about the Trump administration
preventing members of the Trump
administration from testifying not so
much the former US special envoy to
Ukraine Kurt Volker is set to appear on
Thursday and Kurt Volker is the one who
allegedly was texting with Rudy Giuliani
so we're gonna find out some more
information there was he texting with
Giuliani because the Trump
administration in efforts to procure the
quid pro quo had deputized Giuliani from
the State Department in order to go over
there and dig up dirt with the Ukrainian
government or was Kurt Volker basically
just a guy in Ukraine who knew who was
working for the government Nuri Giuliani
Giuliani called him up and said I'd like
to talk to action he said okay here's
his phone number we're about to find
that out meanwhile Tuesday the testimony
of former US ambassador to Ukraine Maria
Nava 'not Ivanovitch which had been
scheduled for Wednesday is now going to
occur next Friday so again they keep
saying this to cover up she's gonna wait
like a week and a half that's not a
cover-up three committees the House
Foreign Affairs Intelligence and
oversight panels have scheduled the
depositions as part of their probe into
whether the president solicited help
from a foreign government to
dirt on his political opponents and
again that remains the central issue but
we are not seeing any additional
information as of yet that suggests that
the quid pro quo either took place or
that was even threatened remember last
week we uncovered three separate stories
that suggested that the Ukrainian
government didn't even know that
military aid was online and even the
aspects of the transcript that look like
they are dealing with military aid where
you have zalenski the presidents of
Ukraine talking about buying javelin
missiles yea I was informed by somebody
in in the defense arena shall we say
that even that has nothing to do with
the so-called quid pro quo with regard
to military aid that had to do with
szalinski trying to butter Trump up by
saying he wanted to buy javelins meaning
that actually the entire call was just
Solinsky trying to butter a Trump up
because foreign leaders are constantly
trying to butter the president up that
doesn't mean that the president was
actually threatening meanwhile the house
is threatening to subpoena the White
House for Ukraine records on Wednesday
the house threatened to subpoena the
White House if it did not comply by
Friday with requests for a broad range
of documents relating to president
Trump's efforts to pressure Ukraine into
investigating Joe Biden and his son
again there is the word pressure again
representative Elijah Cummings of
Maryland the chairman of the Oversight
and Reform Committee notified his
committee of the impending subpoena on
Wednesday he said the White House had
thus far ignored Congress's voluntary
request he said I do not take this step
lightly over the past several weeks the
committee's tried several times to
attain voluntary compliance with our
request for documents wait up what is
this past several weeks business I mean
whoa
what what exactly is that supposed to
mean like this whole thing happened five
seconds ago I mean it's only been going
for two moments so far as we can tell so
yeah again this seems like thus far
overblown Democrats trying to accelerate
the timeline specifically so that the
White House will buck the timeline and
Cummings threatening a subpoena is
obviously an escalation along these
lines the subpoena threat comes as House
Democratic leaders are preparing to lay
out steps in their rapidly unfolding
impeachment inquiry and we will find out
what the State Department Inspector
General is about to say as of today in
just a second or even gets you president
Trump's response to all this plus Bernie
Sanders hospitalized a hearts
has been inserted yet a heart problem
heart surgery all of his campaign events
have been canceled
obviously thoughts and prayers to Bernie
Sanders may disagree with him you may
think that he's a bad guy I think that
his political beliefs are awful but you
don't want to see anybody who is not a
terrorist basically or murderer in in
this position and and so thoughts to his
family even if I wildly disagree with
all of Bernie Sanders's politics
apparently he's conversing and in good
spirits he'll be resting up over the
next few days according to senior
advisor Jeff Weaver we are canceling his
events and appearances until further
notice obviously on a political level
that spells doom for Bernie Sanders's
campaign and it probably means that
Elizabeth Warren is the Democratic
nominee which was the direction that
this was moving anyway so that is indeed
a piece of enormous news we'll get to
more on Bernie Sanders and more on
President Trump and the impeachment
effort in just one second first let's
talk about hiring so hiring can be a
slow difficult process calf al-tohra CEO
Dylan Miska wits needed to hire a
director of coffee for his organic
coffee company he was having some
trouble finding qualified applicants
they switch to zip recruiter zip
recruiter doesn't depend on candidates
finding you it finds them for you it's
technology identifies people with the
right experience and then invites them
to apply to your job so you will get
qualified can't that it's fast Dylan
posted his job on zip recruiter said he
was impressed by how quickly he had
great candidates apply he also used a
zip recruiters cans at a trading feature
to filter his applicants so he could
focus on the most relevant ones and that
is how Dylan found his new director of
coffee in just a few days with results
like that it is no wonder that four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day and here at the Daily
wire we have tons of employees and we
are constantly thinking about how to
upgrade those employees like say that
you had an employee named Donovan and
the guy just looked like Henry Cavill I
mean the guy was just a studly looking
dude and you thought to yourself that's
really intimidating to have this person
around the office I'd like to replace
this Donovan fellow with somebody who's
not quite as good looking without
violating the appropriate laws well I
would be going to look at zip recruiter
com CY zip recruiter is effective for
businesses of all sizes try zip
recruiter for free and our web address
zip recruiter comm slash a Daily wire
that a zip recruiter comm slash Dai ly
WI re zip recruiter comm slash a daily
wire super corner is indeed the smartest
way to
okay we'll get some more of that Bernie
Sanders stuff in just a minute because
at the moment it is breaking news but
president Trump meanwhile is blowing
back against the whistle blower so while
the Democrats are pushing forward
president Trump is raged tweeting so
over the last 72 hours
he's been raged tweeting up a storm and
this is where the Democratic case has
shifted you're starting to see it shift
from maybe Trump did something for
criminal to Trump is a big poopoo head
really because Trump started tweeting a
lot of stuff and then people are like oh
my god I can't believe he tweets all
this stuff okay if you still find from
tweeting like a madman somehow shocking
appalling so if it adds a new level of
pressure to your day and stress to your
day if you believe that this is like
every time he tweets to new level of low
may I suggest that you take a chill pill
because the fact is that this is what
Trump's gonna do it's what he's always
done it's so funny whenever I say this
people like well if Obama tweeted this
you take it seriously correct because
Barack Obama was a serious human being I
don't know what you want from me having
Donald Trump is the President of the
United States which means that we should
take him with a certain amount of
seriousness when he does things but when
he says things really like an we're
gonna pretend that everything Donald
Trump says is well considered
thought-out policy and official
statement from the White House I
remember there was a there's a big
debate early on in Trump's
administration over whether his tweets
amounted to actual statements from the
White House we were like yes and so
people started releasing these on White
House on White House stationery right
it's kind of a joke and it was obvious
that this was not official statements
from the White House it was obvious that
Trump just got up in the morning and he
was like sitting on the toilet watching
Fox News and he was just tweeting and
yet whenever he does this view it oh my
god it's so terrible okay if you really
think that this he was elected in part
because of this there'll be a referendum
on his tweeting habits in 14 months you
can talk about it anyway here's what
Trump tweeted he tweeted so if the
so-called whistleblower has all
secondhand information and almost
everything he has said about my perfect
call with the Ukrainian president is
wrong much to the embarrassment of
Pelosi and chef why aren't we entitled
to interview and learn everything about
the whistleblower and also the person
who gave all the false information to
him this is simply about a phone
conversation that could not have been
nicer warmer or better no pressure at
all as confirmed by Ukrainian press it
is just another Democrat hoax
is there something
in this tweet that are true some things
then in this tweet that are not true
that is true that the Ukrainian
president said he was not pressured it
is also true that I am very skeptical
that the whistleblower did not have
outside legal help on that letter that
he wrote I'm also skeptical the
whistleblower is not actually working
with Democrats behind the scenes
considering that Adam Schiff was
tweeting out the exact points of the
whistleblower report two weeks before he
was supposed to know about it
with that said the whistleblower was not
wrong about the call I mean the details
of the call there's one detail of the
call that was wrong the vast majority of
the details were correct
anyway Trump says as I learned more and
more each day I'm coming to the
conclusion that what is taking place is
not an impeachment it is a coup intended
to take away the power of the people
their vote their freedoms their Second
Amendment
religion military border wall and their
god-given rights as a citizen of the
United States of America okay and this
is obviously a wild overstatement
impeachment is a political process even
if it moves forward in the house it's
probably going nowhere in the Senate in
or afraid to take place it has to happen
outside the legal system there's no such
thing as a legal coup a legal Goo's are
not things are there they're things that
can be done to Austin and legal dictator
but working within the system to oust a
sitting president within the impeachment
system is not in fact a coup and for
president Trump to call it that is dumb
okay that is a silly thing to say
however is anyone supposed to be
surprised here or like why are we
supposed to pretend that President Trump
tweeting things out is supposed to be
the big disqualifier and yet oddly
enough that's exactly what Democrats and
many Democrats are now claiming or is
that because Trump is a poopoo head
right this is really this is this I keep
saying poopoo head because that is the
best way to describe the sort of labels
that they are throwing at Trump right
they're not accusing him of actual
criminal activity really they're not
accusing him of violating his oath of
office in any serious way they're
accusing him of being somebody who they
don't like who mouths off a lot on
Twitter and that I guess is their case
for him being impeachable and I don't
really see that I got to be honest with
you usually impeachment requires a crime
and so you see for example Joaquin
Castro
who's out there you know the the failing
Democratic well he's a representative
right the representative Castro and he
is a 2020 Democratic candidate for the
presidency I'm sorry his brother is who
lien is running
joaquin who is his twin brother is
representative Joaquin Castro is on CNN
and he was out there saying well Trump
is gonna bring harm to the whistleblower
Oh God really we're gonna do this
routine
so he's impeachable because he's
tweeting he doesn't like the
whistleblower yes I'm sure
wait really this this Democratic line
which is so irritating and so stupid and
has been trotted out by people like
Ilhan Omar repeatedly that if you
criticize her if you say that she's a
bad Congress person you're actually
threatening her with violence and
somebody who has 24/7 security because
of legit threats and violence I can
pretty well tell the damn difference
between a threat of violence and people
who just don't like what what I say and
are saying mean things about me but
Democrats in an effort to stretch
impeachment beyond its natural
boundaries like oh well Trump is gonna
harm the whistleblower this is
impeachable the president at this point
has been very abusive of The
Whistleblower Protection Act and really
is is basically on the verge of not only
revealing the identity or getting
somebody else to reveal the identity of
the whistleblower but also bringing harm
to that person it's getting quite scary
the president's behavior and his words
and what that could conjure up okay and
then my favorite part of this is that
Castro says that right the Trump is
gonna bring harm to the whistleblower
and this is obviously a very very very
bad thing super super bad and then
Maxine Waters goes on TV well actually
she tweets she tweets I'm calling on the
GOP to stopped from filthy talk of
whistleblowers being spies and using mob
language implying they should be killed
impeachment is not good enough for Trump
he needs to be imprisoned and placed in
solitary confinement but for now
impeachment is the imperative
okay so Trump says he doesn't like the
whistleblower and he calls him a traitor
because bill weld called him a traitor
and everybody's calling each other
traitors these days Maxine Waters
suggests the sitting president of the
United States should be imprisoned and
placed in solitary confinement
what does Julio and Castro have to but
what does Joaquin Castro I have to say
about that well that's fine that's just
her being passionate guys that's it I
have a lot of respect for Maxine Waters
and she's a very passionate person and
has felt very strongly for a long time
that the president has broken the law
and so you see those you see that in her
words I think a lot of Americans have
been very upset and outraged about the
president's conduct I think all of us
want to make sure that this process is a
fair one that
there is due process for the president
and all the other witnesses that are
gonna come forward but we're committed
to getting the bottom of what happened
she's just a passionate person that's it
so when she threatens to put the
president in jail in solitary
confinement that's her being passionate
when Trump yells about the whistleblower
that's him being impeachable and
horrible and terrible and no-good and
very bad and this is part of the the
broader Democratic agenda at this point
to do legitimize Trump as president not
on the basis of actual crimes but based
on who Trump is as a person well if you
want to do that we have a thing called
elections you can do that but that's not
what Democrats are doing instead they
seem to continually be broadening out
the scope of the impeachment of the
impeachment itself of the impeachment
inquiry of the impeachment grounds and
that is ridiculous as we'll see that
actually ties into a broader agenda on
the part of many people on the Left
which is to use legal methods and
silencing methods to shut down
opposition rather than winning the
argument right they have an election
they want to beat Trump they can just do
this in 14 months but they're not doing
that instead they're pursuing
impeachment got some more of that in
just one second first that's how you
about something cool that happened in
our house over rough shoshanna's right
before Rosh Hashanah we received in the
mail from a company called paint your
life a portrait a full-on huge portrait
of my family it's just great we were
able to put it over the fireplace it
looks beautiful it really changes the
tenor of our house if you want to give a
truly meaningful gift you have to try
paint your life calm so here is the way
that it works you you get you take a
picture and you send it in to paint your
life calm and they will send you back an
original painting of yourself or your
kids your family or a special place or a
cherished pet at a price you can afford
from paint your life calm you don't have
to hire some artist and then have the
artist sit with you and you have your
portrait painted like Napoleon or
something instead you send them the
picture and instead they send you back a
true painting done by hand by a
world-class artist created from your
favorite photo makes a fantastic gift
for birthdays anniversaries graduations
you choose the artist who's working most
admire and you work with them throughout
the process until every detail is
perfect and there is no risk if you
don't love the final painting your money
is refunded so I mean that's a pretty
awesome awesome deal it makes a
fantastic gift go check it out right now
again we got that family portrait it is
fantastic it sits above our fireplace
right now right now is a limited time
offer you get 30% off your painting that
is correct 30% off and free shipping
which is a great offer to get that
special offer
text the word bet
to 64000 that 64,000 text been ven to
64000 text been 64,000 when you support
our show you support our sponsors
message and data rates may apply go
check them out at text bend the sixty
four thousand and get yourself a great
gift and one for your family it really
is fantastic ok so as I say there's part
of a broader impeachment agenda here and
that is to continue broadening out the
actual accusation you can see it from
will Wilkinson who writes a piece at the
New York Times today he's vice president
for research at the Democrat leaning
niskanen Center and the entire piece is
about how Trump ought to be impeached
because he has disqualified himself from
running why the president's brazed an
attempted cheating has taken decided at
the ballot box off the menu impeachment
is imperative right beta O'Rourke said
in March I think the American people are
going to have a chance to decide this at
the ballot box in November 2020 but says
Wilkinson this is no longer a tenable
position it's not tenable to allow an
election to go forward Trump has to be
impeached because otherwise he's gonna
cheat he's gonna win the election by
cheating it's hilarious to watch his
Democrats claim that Trump is going to
do this while simultaneously claiming
that Trump claiming the Democrats are
going to do this is somehow impeachable
so just to get this straight if Trump
says it's a coup and they're cheating
that's impeachable if Democrats say that
Trump is cheating and will engage in a
coup then that's totally fine and not
only that it should be grounds from
teaching Trump so I mean that is heads I
win tails you lose right there Wilkins
said syn says this is no longer a
tenable position the president's bungled
bid to coerce Ukraine's leader into
helping the Trump twenty20 re-election
campaign smear arrival struck decided at
the ballot box off the menu of
reasonable opinion forever forever so
apparently whatever happens with the
vote will be illegitimate at good news
for President Trump even if he loses he
wins now he's apparently the vote is
illegitimate Wilkinson says Trump's
brazen attempt to cheat his way into a
second term stands so scandalously
exposed there can be no assurance of a
fair election if he's allowed to stay in
office resolving the question question
of the president's fitness at the ballot
box isn't really an option much less the
best option when the question boils down
to whether the ballot box will be
stuffed impeachment is therefore
imperative so in other words they still
haven't proved quid pro quo but because
Trump and his campaign were digging in
Ukraine for dirt this apparently
perverts the election beyond all
reasonable measure and thus all results
are perverse well there's only one
problem with that Hillary Clinton in
2016 worked with the Ukrainian embassy
in order to dig up dirt on Trump did
that make the results of the election
illegitimate it did not it did not hey
Rudy Giuliani is out there by the way
making the case that he's going to be
able to prove that Barack Obama ordered
Hillary Clinton and the Democrats to dig
up dirt in Ukraine we'll see if this is
true or not or whether this is just
another overplay by Rudy the reason why
I was investigating and the reason why
the president United States had an
obligation to ask the president of
Ukraine to follow up on these
allegations because there is substantial
and I don't want to exaggerate it but
pretty close to overwhelming evidence
including a finding by a Ukrainian court
that Hillary Clinton and the Democrats
cooperated with Ukrainians with the
order coming directly from the White
House in January of 2017 to dig up dirt
on her political opponent and they did
okay so this is Rudy's case and by the
way the case that the Joe Biden and
Hunter Biden there's something corrupt
there is not insanely weak now it's not
as strong as I think people have made it
out to be but there are serious
questions to be asked about Hunter and
Joe Biden Joe definitely knew that
Hunter was making money off his name
does that impact his actual policy
toward Ukraine that is at best dicey but
still the the case that the Democrats
seem to be making over and over is that
they can just keep broadening out this
inquiry until it's meaningless
again Wilkinson is not making a case
that natural quid pro quo happened he's
just assuming that it did right this is
the this I guess is is the grounds for
impeachment is that he's not going to
allow an actual election to go for and
it turns out that that is not the only
Democratic case that's being made today
as you'll notice whenever the
impeachment grounds get less and less
specific they get more and more
passionate that seems to be the way that
this works when this started off was
supposed to be a very narrowly focused
inquiry with a very narrow point of a
very narrow end goal or end point and
that does not seem like what this is
turning into it seems like instead it is
broadening out and like the case for and
each man is broadening out over and over
and over and by the way I should mention
that while Rudy Guiliani is out there
talking about how Joe Biden ought to be
investigated and Republicans and Trump
are saying Joe Biden ought to be
investigated and they're saying that's a
legitimate point of inquiry given the
fact that Ukraine is requesting is
requesting help and good relationship
with us and therefore we want to make
sure that corruption is taken care of
now with all of that it is amazing the
same people on the Left who suggest that
people on the right are shying away from
the Trump investigation because they're
afraid of what they're gonna find they
are they're saying over and over and
over there's nothing to find with the
Biden stuff nothing whatsoever how do we
know this well because we know this
because there can't be anything because
we know this here is Komal Harris doing
this routine you're elected president
would you allow this son or daughter of
your vice president to serve on the
board of a well company outside this
country I think the problem that we've
got
again with with this issue is that it's
a distraction from the fact that look as
far as I'm concerned leave Joe Biden
alone just leave him alone
on this issue of what this president has
done that has been about corrupting
America's democracy being in cahoots
with a foreign leader - yet again try
and manipulate the election of the
President of the United States
bad judgment though and I'm not gonna be
distracted by what this president is
trying to play okay my favorite part of
that is where she starts laughing
hysterically about Joe Biden and his son
that's always a good sign when Kamala
Harris laughs nervously you know that
she thinks there's actually there there
okay we'll get to more of this in a
second plus of course Bernie Sanders
effectively dropping out of the race
today thanks to a health problem we'll
get to that in just one second first
great news for another Kingdom fans the
third final season is here at last this
Monday October 7th episodes 1 & 2 will
be released but if you're a subscriber
you get exclusive access to both of
those episodes this Friday October 4th
so do not wait subscribe now also
seasons 1 & 2 are available on daily
wire.com and iTunes and YouTube make
sure you check those out and get caught
up and as I say you should go subscribe
generally because the fact is there are
people on the Left who as we will see
are very much interested in destroying
the ability of conservatives to get
their message out when you subscribe you
make sure that we can continue to bring
you the truth and the analysis that you
need when you get the annual
subscription you get this the very
greatest in beverage of vessels the
leftist years hot or cold tumblr it is
indeed that magnificent go check that
out right now for 99 bucks a year you'll
make your life better a $9.99 a month we
are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so as I keep saying the the goal of the
Democrats and and many in the media
seems to be to broaden out the the scope
of the rationale for Trump's impeachment
from quid pro quo which would be an
actual legal standard - he's a meanie
and we don't like him so Thomas Friedman
has a a really famously awful column
today Thomas Friedman is an awful awful
columnist I've said for years that if
you want Thomas Friedman to write a nice
column about you all you have to do is
off from a hotel suite and a nice place
for a night
he would go to around and people would
offer him a nice hotel suite and Thomas
Friedman of the New York Times really
Iran a wonderful open country with a
regime that it's been misunderstood if
you buy him a nice suite in in China
he'll write you a piece about how the
United States should emulate China's
one-party system well today he has a
piece in The New York Times talking
about how to impeach Trump and here's
how it opens you ready for this I'm
going to discuss impeachment today but
first I want to talk about the National
Symphony Orchestra's opening concert and
gala last Saturday night
it was very revealing and mid concert
the chairman of the Kennedy Center David
Rubenstein came out to greet the
audience and the VIPs he welcomed the
different ambassadors and then he went
through the cabinet members present and
then the Supreme Court justices he
introduced Justice Samuel Alito who got
a smattering of applause then he
introduced Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg
seated in the balcony first many women
in the audience stood up to applaud and
then everyone stood up and then everyone
applauded and then everyone applauded
more and then some people cheered and
then some whistle then it went on and on
it was extraordinary I've been to a lot
of Kennedy Center concerts and a few
when the president's sitting in his
official box was introduced but I've
never witnessed anything like the
reception for Justice Ginsburg and this
was not a totally liberal audience there
were many older GOP donors and corporate
types here okay
just quick note it was pretty much a
totally liberal audience it's the
Kennedy Center event okay in New York
that means there are like seven
Republicans and if they are Republicans
in New York good shot that they are not
really hardcore Republicans they're in
New York this was a spontaneous
bipartisan expression of respect for and
longing for a national leader of
integrity and humility by the way Ruth
Bader Ginsburg's an awful justice hey I
also pray for her health because the
fact is we should pray for the health of
all of our officials in in public
positions but she's a terrible justice
was ruled terribly on virtually every
major ruling of last
years but basically Freeman is saying
Ginsberg is a person of class who
unifies the country but Trump is
classless and should be impeached
so that's Thomas Friedman's case so
we've had Wilkinson's case which is
Trump won't let an election go forward
which is nonsense and then you have
Friedman's case which is everyone likes
Ruth Bader Ginsburg and then you get
Susan Rice's case which is that nothing
nothing says we should write about
impeachment and corruption and foreign
policy like Susan Rice woman who lied
repeatedly to the American public about
Benghazi writing in the New York Times
she was the national security advisor
from 2013 to 2017 under Barack Obama by
the way you want to know what drives the
right so fully insane about all of this
is the fact that you've got Democrats
sitting there on their high horses when
they engaged in nearly the same activity
repeatedly whether you're talking about
Hillary seeking dirt on Donald Trump
from the Ukrainians or whether you're
talking about Barack Obama pledging
flexibility to the Russians openly on
mic hey but you get Susan Rice writing
for The New York Times about Trump
should be impeached why well because
because joe biden is innocent right she
says joe biden is innocent and Trump is
guilty because she says that Biden had
nothing to do with the Obama policy and
that Biden is fine and that Biden was
backing a good policy nothing there
about how is inappropriate for the Obama
administration to let Biden run up the
the Ukranian policy to lead up the
Ukranian policy when his son was earning
money off his name in Ukraine while
working with groups that were under
investigation nonetheless Susan Rice
making the Khmer 'king the the I D
pushing the point that the Trump
administration is the corrupt
administration as opposed to the
beautiful wonderful great Obama
administration you want to drive people
nuts this is the way to do it I mean
this is full-on gaslighting at this
point right she says the differences in
these two engagements are stark and
Biden's case the purse the purpose of
the intervention was to pursue a widely
accepted US policy objective in the full
light of day in Trump's case it was to
advance a personal political interest in
opposition to the national interest and
it was deliberately hidden from you was
it deliberately hidden from view that
Trump wanted Giuliani in Ukraine I mean
we've known for two years the Giuliani
is running around in Ukraine and as it
turns out the Washington Post agreed I
mean they reported that the transcript
of the call was not hidden for
this specific call was bad because from
hides all the transcripts cuz all of
them leaked this is the stuff that
drives Republicans up a wall it trans
conservatives up a wall is it you'll see
articles from the press repeatedly
suggesting that Trump is engaged in
corruption where if you just flipped the
parties they'd be talking about how
great it was a perfect example today
there's a piece in The Washington Post
called the presidency of one key federal
agencies increasingly compelled to
benefit Trump
um have you maybe you noticed by the way
that um did you that that Obama did the
exact same like there was the Obama IRS
scandal there was the Obama Health and
Human Services scandal there was Obama
utilizing his DOJ as a protection racket
for himself in fast and furious but
apparently according to the Washington
Post it is a great shock at the head of
the executive branch is also the head of
the executive branch they point out that
a series of disclosures has illuminated
president Trump's command over key
federal agencies revealing how he has
compelled them to pursue his personal
and political goals investigate his
enemies and lend legitimacy to his
theories about the 2016 election yes
that's called being the head of the
executive branch this stuff drives
Republicans up the wall for a reason
again if we were talking about Obama the
press would be cheering right now and by
the way the best case in point Eric
Holder the head of the DOJ the Attorney
General who suggested that he was Barack
Obama's wingman now says that Attorney
General William bar may have crossed
political lines Eric Holder said that
are we supposed to not laugh out loud
to see how the president is now involved
in trying to help the Attorney General
in that effort
gives me pause I think the Attorney
General needs to be a little more
sensitive to the appearance that that
gives you have to not only be
substantively neutral you have to appear
to be neutral when you are the Attorney
General of the United States and I fear
that he has crossed a political line I
mean does this man own a mirror our
mirror is illegal where Eric Holder
lives you have to appear to be neutral
you literally call yourself Barack
Obama's wingman he declared executive
privilege on your behalf and fret and
fast and furious this sort of stuff it's
because there's a generalized belief in
the United States that there's a miasma
of corruption in Washington DC that the
swamp exists then when Trump is kind of
swampy sometimes people are like okay
well and
really because sorry if you think that
the world began spinning when Donald
Trump was elected president you may have
missed the past 20 years in American
politics I mean well I think that this
is part of a broader agenda
unfortunately impeachment is indicative
of broader lefty mindset that has set in
which is that even if you don't have the
goods you use what you have to silence
your opposition again there's an
election in 14 months all the Democrats
have to do if they wish to win and
simply go forward to the election and
make a good case for themselves instead
they're pushing impeachment and this is
part and parcel of a broader radical
left attempt to shut down all opinions
they do not like and so for example you
have Kamala Harris is suggesting today
that Donald Trump's Twitter account
should be suspended he's the President
of the United States here she is on CNN
desperately seeking attention
I mean she's basically become Glenn
Close in fatal attraction boiling a
rabbit for attention here she is when
you look at what he's been tweeting
today directed at the whistleblower
directed it at so many people you know I
frankly think that based on this and all
we've seen him do before including
attacking members of Congress that he
frankly should be his Twitter account
should be suspended when the President
of the United States speaks her words
are very powerful and should be used in
a way that is not about belittling much
less harming anyone
and this president has I think never
fully appreciated that responsibility so
he should be barred from Twitter
according hummel harris it's funny how
comfortable the left is with deep
platforming people they just don't like
Kara Swisher makes the same case the
same Kara Swisher who once suggested a
solution wash Kiki the head of YouTube
that I should be barred from YouTube
because her son watches my videos I'm
sorry that I make a convincing case your
kid Kara but like now here she is saying
Trump is too dangerous for Twitter it's
time to bar him do you get the feeling
that there's a group of people in the
United States who just don't want to
hear the other people's opinion I've
never called for Kara Swisher to be
barred
I've never suggested the common lie
Harris should be barred from Twitter
that would be absurd I mean there are
people who target me day in and day out
on Twitter I've never called for any of
them to be barred unless they're making
actual violent threats to me but this is
part and parcel of a basic attempt to
pressure everyone so there you're gonna
use the pressure tactics
in order to get rid of a president you
don't like not elections you're going to
use the pressure tactics against
advertisers to get rid of shows that you
don't like not just not listening to the
shows not the ratings and you're going
to try and pressure big tech to crack
down on opinions you don't like not
simply tuned out from those opinions
which would be the proper policy which
by the way raises the issue Facebook has
now put forward a policy about elections
Nick Clegg who's the VP of global
affairs and communications put forward
this policy and it's a pretty it's a
pretty decent policy the basic policy is
that they are not going to referee a
political debates and prevents a
politician speech from reaching its
audience and being subject to public
debate and scrutiny so Facebook exempts
politicians from third party party
fact-checking program so very often
Facebook has what I think is is a dumb
system of third party fact checkers who
are very often left right you'll see
Snopes
or you will see politifact and these are
left-leaning left-leaning fact-check
sites and they will use that as an
excuse to go after particular stories
I've always argued that that's fool
foolishness because bad data in means
bad data out there are very few
right-wing fact-checking sites there
probably should be one but there aren't
okay but at least Facebook is not
applying that to politicians because
that effectively would make them the
great truth arbiters in politics and
that is an enormous mistake they said we
will not send organic content or ads
from our politicians to third party
fact-checking partners for review when a
politician shares previously to bunk'd
contents including links videos and
video videos and photos we plan to
demote that content display related
information from fact checkers and
reject its inclusion in advertisements
again all of this seems perfectly
reasonable doesn't matter facebook is
being attacked why because the left
would like to turn Facebook into the
arbiter of truth but the lefty arbiter
of truth that's why Elizabeth Warren is
targeting Facebook too again this is not
about Elizabeth Warren just disliking
Facebook as a big company this is about
the Democrats threatening Facebook so
they can control of it politically Mark
Zuckerberg knows this by the way right
there was lead to audio of him over the
weekend pointing out that Elizabeth
Warren was an existential threat to his
company she is she's an existential
threat to big tech and while the right
may celebrate the downfall of big tech
the fact is you don't want Democrats in
control of big tech that's really what
this is about
Democrats in the same way that want a
bar Trump from Twitter they would like
to see Facebook broken ups they can then
control Facebook and determine what it
is that you see and you here and
naturally the press are cheering us on
right the New York Times has a headline
Zuckerberg hates Warren's plan to break
up Facebook she doesn't care
well okay so what so uh I mean but who
is the aggressor here Mark Zuckerberg
built up a bajillion dollar company that
affects billions of people around the
world and Elizabeth Warren is gonna
willy-nilly grab the power of the
American government try to break it up
and she's the courageous one she'd until
Denny thing she's never built anything
she worked as a law professor is all
very silly okay meanwhile gotta give you
the update on Bernie Sanders as I
mentioned earlier Bernie Sanders has now
had a heart since surgery after eight
after chest discomfort according to
Politico breaking news Bernie Sanders
experienced chest discomfort during a
campaign events on Tuesday he had two
stents inserted to address a blockage in
an artery his campaign announced he is
you know 78 years old so this is not
exactly a massive shock how old is
Bernie now is he 80 I think he may be 80
so he is he's sorry he's 78 I was right
the first time he's getting up there and
this is by the way this is why when
people say older politicians may have
health problems and then everybody's
like that's ageist no that's called a
reality with age come health problems
according to a senior advisor Jeff
Weaver he said senator Sanders is
conversing in in good spirits he'll be
resting up over the next few days we are
canceling his events and appearances
until further notice we will continue to
provide appropriate updates Sanders has
maintained a relentless campaign
scheduled over the past several months
he is the oldest candidate in the
Democratic field but has projected vigor
be lying his age the news came a day
after Sanders posted a robust 25 million
dollar fundraising haul in the third
quarter of the year but as he's been
eclipsed - but in recent weeks by
Elizabeth Warren in the polls so
apparently the Sanders campaign
cancelled the entirety of its recently
scheduled ad buy in Iowa on broadcast
television
they'd announced a 1.3 million dollar ad
buy on Monday in the state that was set
to begin on Thursday
Kamala Harris was was eager to jump in
and wish him the best
she says she looks forward to seeing him
on the campaign trail soon I am sure
that is not true
but it is certainly true that you know
listen you never want to see politicians
put out of it by health obviously
benefit
cheri politically and putting aside the
human aspect which is you know thoughts
and prayers to the Sanders family
with that said politically speaking
obviously Elizabeth Warren now looks to
be the heavy favorite for the nomination
because the the going theory for Joe
Biden was that Elizabeth Warren would
split the boat with Bernie Sanders on
the Socialist Left well now that Bernie
Sanders looks to be out of the race for
the foreseeable future there is no way
he's gonna recover coming back in
there's now a two-person race it is now
Elizabeth Warren and Joe Biden and Joe
Biden is collapsing in the polls
according to the national polling
average Biden is up just a point and a
half on Elizabeth Warren there are now
several polls that show them in the dead
heat there's an economist YouGov poll
that came out yesterday showing that
Warren is now up six on Biden there's a
Monmouth poll showing that Warren is up
three on Biden so Warren is obviously in
commanding position in the early running
here she is leading in Iowa Sanders is
at 12% all of that probably kicks to
Elizabeth Warren in New Hampshire
Elizabeth Warren is again running within
the margin of error and Nevada she's
running inside the margin of error the
betting odds on Elizabeth Warren are now
up to 49% to Biden's 22 percent so she
is the prohibitive favorite in this
election that means that what we are
looking at right now is Donald Trump
versus Elizabeth Warren and that by the
way does explain at least in part why
the Democrats are moving forward with
the impeachment inquiry even if they're
not able to come up with any hard
evidence of a quid pro quo that is if
they can portray Trump as corrupt and
then they can portray Elizabeth Warren
as the fighter against corruption the
populist fighter against corruption
she wins well that's a very scary
prospect because she's a dangerous
politician with wild left views man is
gonna be one hell of a race okay let's
do a quick thing I like and then the
thing I hate and we will be out of here
so a quick thing that I like so there's
a lot of talk very frequently about
racial bias in the justice system well
there is a case that happened in Dallas
of I guess it was last year it would
have been in which an officer and
off-duty officer amber Geiger she's
white she was in the wrong apartment she
walked into the wrong apartment she came
home from work one night last year
believing she'd found an intruder inside
her apartment she then shot the man
inside the man she shot was not an
intruder but her name
mm gene a 26 year old black accountants
who's watching TV and eating ice cream
in the apartment he rents it directly
above miss Geiger's on Tuesday jeans
family braced themselves for the
possibility his death would be treated
like many others across the country in
which police officers have been cleared
of wrongdoing but that moment never came
instead a dallas county jury found
geiger 31 guilty of murder choosing the
more serious conviction over a lesser
option of manslaughter and that seems
perfectly appropriate for this fact
pattern the case did not fit into the
familiar narratives of police killings
in which the officers fired their
weapons on duty and it just goes to show
again that the notion that everyone in
the United States is eagerly awaiting
police shootings of black people by
white officers is just not true
it's always funny the left tends to pick
out cases where the fact pattern is
murky in order to make the case that
people don't pay enough attention to
black folks being killed and that is not
the case right I mean they never talk
about the case the case of a man in
South Carolina who shots a black man
shot to death from behind by a police
officer he planted the gun on him that
officer once jail they never talk about
that because we all agree on the fact
pattern instead they talk about Michael
Brown where the fact pattern is in
dispute or Eric garner or the fact
pattern is in dispute in this case the
fact pattern was not in dispute and so
this officer will go to jail for a very
very long time as it is appropriate
because if you shoot somebody in
apartment not your own that means that
you should go to jail okay time for a
quick thing that I hate okay so there is
a new ruling from a judge about Harvard
University New York Times reports a
federal judge on Tuesday rejected claims
that Harvard had intentionally
discriminated against Asian American
applicants in a closely watched case
that presented one of the biggest legal
challenges to affirmative action in
years the lawsuit against the university
came from a group hoping to overturn a
long-standing Supreme Court precedent
that allows race to be considered as one
factor among many in admissions but
prohibits universities from using racial
quotas the group argued Harvard favored
black and Hispanic applicants at the
expense of another minority group Asians
which is true the judge rejected the
plaintiffs argument said the university
methy strict constitutional standard for
considering race in its admissions
process she defended the benefits of
diversity not not ideal
Oh diversity not experiential diversity
racial diversity which again there is no
benefit to racial diversity on its own
as a matter of experiential diversity
sure as a matter of socio-economic
diversity sure as a matter of viewpoint
diversity sure but why'd you make a
difference that a black person and white
person are in a room and somehow this is
like better than two white people are
two black people in a room is beyond me
without any other metric that's silly
but you said diversity will foster the
tolerance acceptance and understanding
that will ultimately make race conscious
admissions obsolete okay they've been
saying that for 40 years now since crude
review Bollinger in the late 70s and the
course is not letting up on this
nonsense so I do there is a great irony
to the fact that now the courts are
standing up for diversity by barring
Asians from Harvard well done everybody
well done everybody
alrighty we'll be back here a little bit
later today with all the updates on
Bernie Sanders health and on the
impeachment inquiry and all of it
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
shana tova i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show well I guess we
have to cover this stupid Ukraine story
an amazingly shameless and naked attempt
to discredit the people who are in the
process of exposing the Obama
administration spine campaign on Donald
Trump so that's unpleasant but we'll
also have the mail back so all your
problems will be solved woohoo that's on
the Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew